foreign
he immediately
I thought you won't tell me I'm muted
after the whole intro bro how am I
supposed to know what you're saying man
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the donor you're joined with five you're
joined with an army and Gardener oh how
you doing bro oh my God can y'all see me
good or is it yeah it exposes too much
out here right it's good
your hats absorbing it all ah mashallah
guys 100 viewers already in the live
stream smash that like button to
everyone that tuned in
on her bro
how's it going man
bro how you feel being outside right now
uh
it's good
I have nobody set up so here I am I'm
envious bro but I say that like with
mashallah you know I'd rather be outside
why why I'm inside bro listen so my
man's outside no lights no mic look at
that setup bro I'm here with like three
lights bro it still doesn't measure up
I mean it's not the best though I'm
Overexposed as you can tell
[Music]
um
I mean no no honestly bro you're hot is
absorbing a lot of it so it's fine Rami
how about you how you doing
man I'm doing good I'm doing good I got
my uh my Tim Hortons coffee no
sponsorship and uh I'm feeling good how
about you man
uh good bro God another day another
opportunity
and I said we go right into some of
these questions bro
all right now I forgot we're doing a q a
today yeah bro it's been a while yeah
all right
bless you
another question
your YouTube member mashallah
Sharif right I have a bunch of questions
bro throw them out our way today's the
day
can't wait to watch this stream bro I
can't wait either
foreign
what exactly
whatever you guys like within reason
obviously you can't ask like some like
hella personal questions you know
Angel got a very uh very thick hijab bro
he doesn't like to let too many people
in
uh
the use of Rights I like green tea okay
okay martial look at that ginseng
um okay let's see I gotta start with the
questions any questions we're gonna go
right at it
um okay Rami we got a troll question
what do you what do you say today is
going to be uh about troll questions
should we address any should we not it
depends on the question let me know
where is it who asked one from my
channel
1206 pm
so 6 p.m oh that's a while ago
let me see
it's okay I can't find it let's just
ignore it for now okay call us
oh my channel I see honestly I don't
think that's a troll question to be
honest I know I like it profile pictures
like a laughing emoji or a mustache
Emoji but I don't think that's uh
a troll question people some people
actually ask that let's go with it you
can you can you can read it out and
address it while I address it I'll put
up the other comments all right all
right so why are Muslims so humiliated
and oppressed everywhere so a lot of
people ask this question like you know
if Muslims are upon the right religion
Islam is right then how come Muslims are
being you know tortured accumulated and
so on and so forth everywhere
um it kind of if assuming that this is
what he's asking that kind of is a
fallacious way of thinking that you know
Asha Allah he says in the Quran do you
think you're going to be left alone
saying that you believe and you will not
be tested he says we'll test them with
loss of life and hunger and and so on
and so forth he also says that he'll you
know for example he'll give people
provisions and that's a test he'll take
provisions and that's a test Annie so
allowing the Muslims to be you know
tested or to be murdered and and so
martyred and so on and so forth even if
it's all over the world it's actually
one of the signs the process um he said
that basically corruption would be all
over the Earth which means the Muslims
doing it to other Muslims non-muslims
doing it to Muslims some Muslims doing
it to non-muslims that everyone's
oppressed everywhere even in the West in
one form or another we're oppressed in
different ways you know telling people
they can do whatever the hell they want
is a form of them ending up oppressing
themselves and well that's another topic
but hope that helps y'allah
just in case you didn't get the message
on text stream yards a little buggy with
audio so let's all keep ourselves on
muted today and then when you speak we
can just unmute it and then oh do you do
you terribly mind doing that for me
because if not I'm just gonna be like oh
bro in that case I got you just just uh
when I can sense you're gonna speak I'll
just only eat them
okay Bismillah
let me quickly all right there we go all
right so next question
uh Kazi writes one will fight upload a
new travel Vlog bro wonderful question
it's been a while I've been to Africa
about I'll be honest with you guys it's
probably been like five six months and I
keep saying I want to get around to
editing the Vlog
but I don't but insha Allah you guys are
my word because I've been getting too
many of these inshallah within a month
you guys will see it on my channel
Insha'Allah and uh make sure you guys
subscribe to our channels too you can
click on our on our profile on our
Channel page click on channels you'll
see rami's Channel Romney's trying to
revamp his channel Insha'Allah click on
my channel you got on host Channel 2
self-improvement Bismillah
next question is is are supplements
necessary to gain muscle uh my take on
this before Arnold jumps in is no okay
unless you have some type of like a
nutritional deficiency or anything like
that consider those vitamins and
minerals maybe even then try to get it
from like actual food sources they're
more like you know bioavailable more
absorbable if you want to get whey
protein because you cannot hit your
protein intake every day that's the only
thing I'll mention but you really don't
need a lot of this stuff
um I'm not pro-creatine or pre-workout
or anything but I don't know what do you
think
as convenes
like you said bro like we don't need it
but it's convenient so like if if
someone let's say Romney's over here for
breakfast he has three eggs with a a
little bowl of oatmeal
let's say for like lunch
family Cooks up I don't know maybe
there's some like rice and chicken some
bland rice and chicken
and then let's say for dinner is family
Cooks up some
they don't cook up anything they just
order some pizza
at this point if you're calculating the
macros
protein-wise this man probably is
getting like less than 100 maybe maybe
100 grams so at that point he would add
like two scoops of protein and that's it
call us
so he wouldn't have to like
basically make it harder on himself
saying no no I need to have I need to
have chicken I need to have meat or
something for dinner or for breakfast I
need to have so-and-so protein like it's
just convenience bro that's it same with
the uh vitamins minerals and creatine as
well because you know creatine you get
that from red meat so if you're not
eating enough red meat then you might as
well just open the recruiting
bro all right next question
wait you're streaming again nice we
never stop streaming alhamdulillah we're
gonna keep streaming one to two times a
week for now until we can raise it up uh
we got the first Super Chat before I go
to that I want to address this question
uh I'll give my Layman take and then I
want Rami to fill in anything that I
might have missed on this
um so I heard this question a video want
to know your thoughts why aren't there
female prophets so to be to be a prophet
you have to be a leader you have to be
someone that comes in a time where there
is political Norms sociological Norms
economic Norms
um jurisprudential norms and you kind of
have to convey divine revelation
now Men by Nature their studies to prove
this are better at confrontation at
challenging Norms being more uh
disagreeable than women by Nature so
this is one thing why I believe
um another reason is as a as a leader as
an Imam you've got to lead prayer so
women because of their Menses one
quarter of the month and this is not a
deficiency or a flaw within them it's
just something that Allah has made them
that way and it's kind of beautiful
because they can have kids that way and
we can but because of that they can't
lead prayer
um period right because they're going to
have their period once a month
um and because of that how can it be you
know a prophet and someone like that
Rami anything else that I might have
missed you can feel free to jump in
um just a general like this is just how
Allah created us and you know Allah
created the men to be prophets and to
fulfill the roles and he didn't create
women to do that some Scholars it's a
minority opinion but some Scholars say
that there were female prophets
um like Maria Malai Saddam some say that
she might have been a prophet
um but uh
the majority opinions that women are not
profits and it's not because oh you know
we're anti-feminism well we are nowadays
but or Not that we're against equality
or you know uh equal opportunity or
whatever it's just that um yeah and you
think about if a woman were to get
pregnant or something you know
how is he supposed to be a prophet when
she's pregnant you know that would be
difficult so Allah he created men with
the capabilities like fight was saying
to go out and give dawa and stuff and
it's just not as a woman would not be as
capable of doing their job so why would
we give the job to someone who's less
capable right it just it wouldn't make
sense but at the end of the day that's
just what Allah will and it's not a
problem unless you're like an angry
feminist to be completely honest
and you said that we don't have female
prophets not because we're anti-feminism
um just to clarify this to everyone
we're still anti-feminism but I'll be
saying that it's not the reason because
of that that we don't have female
prophets uh on her as a nude in his face
maybe the sunlight masha'allah
um what do you think about this and
we'll we'll try to tackle every question
a little bit quicker
um because we got a lot and rights what
do you do when your Iman is low Iman
linguistically doesn't mean Faith a man
linguistically means the acceptance of a
fact right so if you want to have higher
Iman you need to learn more about the
Quran Allah Islam you will literally
increase your Immanuel except more facts
if it is an issue of doubts you don't
know if you actually believe in these
things that you're reading then you have
to deal with it intellectually it's not
an intellectual problem it's an
emotional one then you know I have to
deal with that as well I would go to a
teacher or scholar or someone or maybe
just you know hit us up and whatever the
problem is the problem is inshallah
we'll deal with it Allah
rights are you all reverted
technically
technically but no in the popular sense
of the term uh me and Ramy are born
Muslims brother anha over here on the
right he is a river mashallah
separates Rami what's your favorite
Tim's drink uh the ice cap for sure but
um I a coffee from when I I need just a
normal caffeine boost
mashallah
Sharif writes on her shut up been
watching you since the deep voice videos
I'm happy to see you reverted Masha
Allah but for semen retention what's the
ideal time frame I should be doing it
and do uh nocturnal emissions cancel it
uh
and I was about to say something in
French but um
it all depends bro
it all depends on like how long you can
last before you have this uh thing at
night that you have mentioned in the
comments
um so if it happens like every few days
then
I mean Hollis like
you it's the whole practice in and of
itself which you just mentioned is being
reset every time that you have this
experience at night time it's all right
it's out of your control but the
practice in and of itself of like
retaining you think that you just
released at night so you have to reset
but some people might last a few days
some people my last few weeks a few
months
and the goal is just to focus on other
things that are most important and if
you're really finding a difficult
difficult time to fight the urges I mean
the prophet saws
he prescribed as fasting though
it prescribes the first thing so you
fast and you fast
and you do so Mondays and Thursdays but
I've heard of people doing fast of
like one day is when they know
some people do fast every single day and
they're just eating after
um after modular time every single day
and that's basically like one meal a day
if you really think about it they're
just cutting out the liquids as well
during the daytime
so to answer your question man it really
depends you just
kind of gauge yourself and
really ask yourself what do you need to
be doing in order for you to be married
and then you know keep that to yourself
don't be sharing that with other people
just keep it to yourself and then start
working towards that while you implement
everything that's mentioned for the
practice and then once you get married
it's you're not really
you know I'll be playing that game too
much Marshall bro I'm gonna give that
hoop finesse comment you know over here
but no straight up guys like that
comment because Arnold's giving the
undivided attention we're uh we're about
10 to 15 minutes behind on the comments
I'm still like 12 10. so I don't know oh
God you guys you are speed up I'll speed
up next time I might I might skip
through some of them guys as mentioned
before here uh send the super chat
um it'll come right above everyone
else's comment and I will be able to
address it before everyone else
um
mobile rates do you guys think Don will
revert or is he just another polemist
who has no intention of actually seeking
truth Rami what do you think no one
really knows I think right now like we
talked about before he's kind of you
know hurt by what happened you feel like
he felt like he got ambushed in that
stuff so he went on like an emotional
you know downfall Allah maybe one day
he'll his heart will open up he'll
accept the truth of Islam but for now
let's just leave him alone inshallah
slightly maybe give that right here and
there but
how old are you guys uh I'm 22. I forgot
how old these guys are how old are you
guys I'm 24. oh no you can correct me if
I'm wrong you're 28.
yes
okay next question
uh around me oh no
[Laughter]
oh my God bro this is this is this is
getting too far bro
I plead the fifth next question
Muhammad hijab
I don't know mo money
more money
more problems
okay next alarm let me kind of skip
through these oh let's just super chat
bro uh Yuma worldwide someone could be
preaching and doing your thing is
[Music]
should we plead the fifth on this one
too
um it's it's on an individual basis uh
I'm married so any women stay away
I'm married
one out of four
I don't know what about you
I prefer not to answer these questions
it's a little too uh
Too Close eh my guy was two times bro he
really wants to know why you got a wife
ready
All I'm gonna say is alhamdulillah
that's it that's it
private life is probably like exactly
some stuff all right how do I make my
beard as thick as on house
patience though
patience
and
what's it called the other
the Derma roller
and minoxidil I heard that works I never
did it but I heard that works
um okay okay
what sports do you practice guys
martial arts but really anything
give you basketball
it could be football it could be
skateboarding longboarding
swimming it is what it is anything
really mashallah I'm just I'm just doing
bodybuilding right now that's it trying
to cut down around me what about you
basketball very rarely since on her left
to be honest but um if you consider
bodybuilding then yeah bodybuilding as
well
I'm still working on it
I wanted to Robin get married um
like a month and five days ago or
something like that come on SO emotions
I mean right let's say I'm far from
getting married like maybe seven years
what is your advice for me navigating
this world of fiton this is a legit
question bro boy you got you better get
on top of what you gotta do if you got
seven years you get married that means
you guys seven years where you got to be
put in the work and you're saying you
have seven years but you don't know if
you have seven years a lot of my Allah
might be saying you only have one year
left before you get married
you know like so you you got to be
putting in work and like I said to the
previous question figure out what the
hell you gotta do to prepare yourself
and then you go from there
Marshall and brother liban shout out to
you may Allah bless you for the super
chat
um Hudson writes guys bring I'm Lucifer
podcast bro I talk to him frequently and
it's gonna happen Insha'Allah you just
gotta have some supper guys come on
he's talking the Netflix show called oh
I I heard about that is it controversial
yeah I haven't seen it but from what I
heard yeah just don't watch it it's
funny I guess from what I hear again but
also what I hear don't don't watch him
man yeah okay next question
uh brother Levant to the second Super
Chat Jose may Allah bless you do you
think
will go back to sneako's channel again
sneako was interested in having him back
on again with a learned Christian so
basically guys what's happened since
that live stream is we I'm still in
touch with Nico every now and then you
know we we talk every now and then every
few days or so just to like keep in
touch it's it's not like we've had a
call or anything like that
um with the ship up definitely nothing
like that
um and when I talked to him about the
you know the actual physical uh stream
that he wanted to do without Don without
anyone else just with us with share you
know talking about Islam that's
inshallah gonna happen he's confirmed
for that it's just in the works whenever
we can find the time and uh again may
Allah bless you all we're almost at 200
viewers please smash that like button if
you want to help this push out into the
masses into the public Insha'Allah
um right now we have a couple super
chats so I'm just going to quickly
address those before going anything else
uh brother Sharif
unless you write how to avoid getting
distracted by women what do you guys
think
just don't look bro Allah he tells us in
the Quran to lower our gaze that's
honestly especially from my experience
that's the only way just do not look if
you see them for a Split Second Look
Away I know I might be a bit extra or
whatever in some people's eyes who cares
we're here to please Allah and if you
want to you know be successful and
without any distraction especially the
distraction of women just look away
not easy
oh no bro what do you have to say
well it says I can't unmute on her
because he chose to move himself and my
bad bro I had to uh I had to get some
water so I had to climb up
but um how do you stop being distracted
by women
same thing that Romney said just don't
look well it's really hard I'm not gonna
lie because like you know a lot made us
to where as men were weak and we are
creatures of vision you know we what we
see is
very powerful so it's like look you're
not
punished for the first look
at this second look third look for it
look fit look and so on uh yeah you're
gonna be held accountable for that so if
you see it okay call us but look the
other way like stay focused on what you
gotta do
huge shout out to brother boy sister
Blue Tech and Islam for the stupid shots
for supporting us Rehan writes how does
fired managed to stare at the screen so
seriously I mean even when he laughs he
becomes serious again in no time
sister Saudi Arabs how important is it
for a guy to be financially ready before
marriage and if so to what extent
extremely important this is this is
literally an obligation upon men to be
able to provide for the family however
if a woman wants to pitch in she wants
to give a little bit she wants to
contribute no one's stopping you baby
girl more power to you but it's an
obligation to the man to be able to
fully provide and
who's at this around me is this just me
making it up or what
uh to be able to financially provide
Allah is commended upon men to you know
provide for the woman to maintain and
protect them but at the same time so I
want to answer the second part of the
question to what extent it depends on
the woman you know if if the woman's not
going to be satisfied with a guy who's
making you know minimum wage or whatever
and she just cannot love him because of
that you know I mean it is what it is
maybe she shouldn't marry that guy maybe
that guy shouldn't marry her but if
she's content with not a lot of money
and she just loves him for who he is and
his character and all that stuff his his
Dean is his then Masha Allah
foreign
I can't answer this one I don't know I
know it depends photos you know yeah you
should ask yourself from as far as I
know it depends on the game but uh go
ask a share
more Droids do you guys have any plans
of doing Hijra to a Muslim country
I was thinking about it recently I can't
say for sure but I was thinking about it
how about you guys
um
honestly I love Walden bro I want
whatever Allah has in store for me
exactly it's like the best answer bro
for a lot of these questions
brother Sheriff's advice to become a
content creator avoiding evil eye oh
good question
check out our uh video we did our
podcast we did with brother uh ustad Abu
Ibrahim whose name we talked about Rokia
evil eye
uh Jin a lot of these things and in that
one of the questions was how do you have
a business or how do you become an
influencer or have you ever social media
or YouTube and go to higher Social
positioning without getting you know
answered online left right and center
and I recommend you watch that very uh
very good opportunity right there
Goku black rates everybody head over to
Abu Tamia's Channel and hit like button
on his new video mail a bus we'll start
up with Tamira we filmed the podcast
with them I think over a month ago bro
and we still haven't even dropped it yet
just gotta get around to editing it
inshallah you guys should see it in a
few weeks insha Allah uh find your trip
to Bangladesh with brother Dilly Hussein
still happening inshallah if Allah has a
world
I know I I told Brother Dilly that you
know we're gonna touch base probably
toward the end of the year or early next
year just to confirm if everything's
happening next brother Islam for the
Super Chat Muslims are speaking like
non-muslims help please what do you guys
have to say about that
um uh I mean it's it's a problem in some
cases but it's not always a problem I
mean non-muslims might talk in a certain
way and it might actually help in giving
down that you talk like them but if you
mean and like in swearing and what they
talk about and and what they say which
you know the words that come off your
tongue they could lead you to cover
right there could be statements of
coffee we have to be very careful of
that but the answer is always just yeah
people have to go learn Islam they have
to study under a teacher who's
knowledgeable who has good manners and
once they learn Islam and they fully
fully adopt Islam in their life they
won't want to talk like that Muslims
they won't want to act like them and I
think that is the only solution
how about you guys
I don't even fully understand the the
context
yeah there's a little bit of context
lacking but I do agree wholeheartedly
more or less with what brother Romney
said
um
it's kind of like uh
when you have Muslims who don't dress
Muslim
I'm a Believer rights please go for
three dog all three guys we've all all
three of us have done it the clips that
you see right now we actually filmed it
when we're all together
um a little while ago in a city called
Niagara Falls you might notice that it's
in Clifton Hill and we all did this feed
Bella it just again a lot of Clips a lot
of editing to do you guys will get a 200
a lot
your mic sounds a little bit like you're
underwater yeah I think
yeah it's still audible like we could
understand what you're saying but
I don't know it just sounded a little a
little drowned
my favorite Nasheed artist is uh
Ahmed
but he doesn't make no she's he actually
resides the Quran yo how's the audio
right now
it's good good okay cool I just gotta
keep switching out of it then
what if you want to get married six I
mean
don't don't get this you're gonna be
you're gonna be a real good you're gonna
be real disappointed that's all I'm
gonna say because it's a relationship a
marriage is way more than just that
that's for sure
which one is that
I think he's talking about um the
YouTuber homes the one we heard on the
podcast oh no
no
bro just tell her like if like if if
somebody were to touch a woman sorry I'm
stuttering all over the place because
just think about it someone would have
touch a woman she's like don't touch me
it's like boom you don't touch ever
again that's that's the standard right
so how come we can't just be like oh I
can't touch one I'm almost boom that's
the standard why is it oh how do I tell
her without hurting her feelings and
being respectful and bro listen I'm a
Muslim in Islam we don't touch you know
random women I can't touch you boom no
no you need to touch me is that what
she's gonna say come on man
I know you want to be respectful I think
that's a good thing it's a beautiful
thing to want to be respectful but if
anything if you tell her I'm sorry I'm a
Muslim I can't touch you I know it's
against your Customs while I'm not a
Muslim I'm sorry I'm a Muslim I can't
touch you right I'm not you know like
you guys
call us what is she gonna say you're
gonna get mad then she's being
disrespectful
I'm just I'm just trying to pull up this
Hadith both so I have it right now but
the prophet saws mentioned
um that for a nail of iron to be driven
in the head of one of you would be
better for him than to touch a woman who
is not lawful for him
foreign
context and be like oh well I mean if
I'm just like giving a handshake or a
hug like it's not that big of a deal but
it all starts with little things the
Little Steps yeah yeah guys we got some
super chats a little blast to it night
of decree became a member
bro
zombie man what do you what do you think
about that may Allah bless you bro I
mean I mean next brother Islam is
clarifying his uh previous thing Muslims
justifying Haram and speaking as if it
is as if the way of Islam is wrong
talking as if there is no big deal if we
adopt certain things they know why it's
Haram but they justify such as men
wearing earrings or gold chains or
whatever
this is this is a whole other issue this
isn't just people agreeing with
non-muslims this is people making
Haram and making
Allah talks about people in the Quran
who did that vile people who did that
and they will be punished by Allah for
doing so because not only are they you
know themselves justifying Haram they're
teaching other people that's okay and
then everyone who everyone else who
sings because of you you know you're
getting that sin as well potentially so
it's a very very horrible thing and and
people this is not just a problem of
understanding Islam this is the problem
of understanding like like Akita like
basic belief you have to understand
that there's no one who can make
legislation except for Allah and if you
come and you're saying justifying this
Haram and that Haram you're trying to
put yourself in position of Allah think
about that you're trying to put yourself
in the position of Allah that's
probably horribly punishable so protect
yourself follow Allah and his messenger
and don't make yourself you know your
own God or God of anyone else solid
um Vision rights oh this is a this is a
wonderful question man may Allah bless
you for the Super Chat and uh I really
like this question so what were the
challenges to your Social Circles when
you become or became vocal about Islam
and dropping useless habits do you
condone cutting people off as such is it
egotistic judgmental to do so on her sub
since 2017
let's start with the first one what were
the challenges to your Social Circles
when you became vocal about Islam and
dropping useless habits
um so I'll go first uh the challenges
for Social Circles again
alhamdulillah that Allah has given me
the ability and a lot of our brothers
and sisters mashallah that when they
have in the Deen that they don't get too
much fomo now this fomo thing or fear of
missing out something that plagues a lot
of brothers and sisters when they feel
like okay you know what I know that I
can no longer be going to Shisha bars or
or hookah cafes or I can no longer be
sipping this eating that you know
because I know now it's wrong it's Haram
it's impermissible as a Muslim
um I still kind of want to do it because
everyone's going to do it I don't want
to seem lame I don't want to seem like a
party pooper you know I don't want to
seem like I'm going to be you know kind
of like a buzz kill but the reality is
at the end of the day right is right and
wrong is wrong if you don't want to do
it and other people are forcing you to
do it you got to ask yourself are these
people conducive to myself Improvement
to my journey towards Allah or these
people not what do you guys think about
that
I agree 100 percent
oh no do you have anything you want to
add
uh I agree the only thing that I'll add
is that
you know you can do your part
and like talk to them every now and then
but you're gonna catch on real quick if
people are ever going to be receptive to
what you're doing and what you're saying
um so you know what if people are just
really really not receptive then
is Buddhism you know like you're not
you're not making the intention of
cutting them off and the effort of
cutting them off you just continuing
with your life simple as that [ __ ] so
that's kind of the the next uh question
do you condone cutting people off as
such my my personal philosophy is I I
never caught anyone off I always leave
my door open if if they disrespect you
violate you violate your family or
something that's a different story but
I'm talking about people that you just
outgrow in uh maybe spiritual or in uh
self-improvement type of sense
um you're letting go of some type of
desires that they're still plagued with
you're letting go of Haram that they're
still plagued with maybe you try to you
know Inspire them lead by example it's
not working
um at that point don't really cut
yourself off you know prioritize people
that are more similar to you in your
inner circle
um but still you know if these people
come to you always they're always going
to watch you anyway
um continue being solid and and you know
always be here to to guide them if they
need so
yeah it also depends on who it is like
if it's a family member maybe you you
know you need to distance yourself but
you can't fully cut them off the rest of
your life you know if it's like your mom
your dad even as non-muslims they solve
certain rights over you as their child
and you have certain responsibilities
you have to you know fulfill so if you
have to once in a while visit them give
them a present and you know try and
teach them about stem a little bit you
know inshallah that's something you
should do but if it's a friend like a
group of friends from college or
university or something or from the gym
or whatever and they're all trying to
encourage you to drink and smoke and all
that stuff if you don't change them
which you're probably not because
they're the majority they're going to
change you and in that case you actually
have to cut them off because you know
it's going to lead you to destruction
Allah talked about people in the Quran
who put themselves into fitna and
they're punished on a day of judgment
for that they put themselves into fitna
what do you think you're doing when you
talk to these people you're putting
yourself into a fitness oh all these
people are coming to me and telling me
do this do that I don't want to have to
say no and be the odd one out that's a
fit not in and of itself and then they
lead you to other fittings so you have
to be careful inshaallah an egotistical
judgmental people
um egotistical I'd say you know better
to stay away from them it's not the
worst thing to be friends with them but
it depends on who they are in other
aspects of their character in their life
I think everyone has a little bit of ego
so one glimpse of from someone won't be
like okay let me cut them off judgmental
again it depends if they're like like a
hypocrite or they're judging every
little thing you do and pretending you
should be perfect when they're not okay
cut them off but if they're judging you
here and there like listen you did this
I don't think that was smart you know
actually until I don't I hope you don't
mind if I say this but he's pretty blunt
with what he says a lot of times it just
kind of sometimes comes down he just
says it we're not gonna be like oh on
Hill you're so judgmental you hurt my
feelings I'm gonna you know Screw you
I'm Gonna Leave No it's actually a lot
of the time is very very good judgment
it's very good advice masha'allah and I
think it's helped me in fight in our
lives as well so don't just cut someone
off because they're judgmental
um other factors included maybe cut them
off
all right and just a quick reminder guys
we are wrapping this up in about 10
minutes or so so if you guys really have
an important question send a Super Chat
how do you send a super chat if you have
the live chat there's like a little sign
on the bottom right that's how you send
it that way it comes to the queue if
there's no super chats then I'll go you
know reading questions randomly and no
order
um but we'll go to the next one
so I can't really read that name bro my
contact lenses are blurry I'm a little
far from the screen but
um
created us in the best form why
circumcision if it's healthier shouldn't
the best form the humans already
circumcised naturally
this is this is a good question I think
I think a few people have asked this
before but it depends on what you
consider the best if you if you're for
example if the best means the most
pragmatic pragmatically efficient
pragmatic meaning like it it just it
works the best like for example uh the
most pragmatic car would be the best car
the most efficient car spends the least
amount of gas goes the fastest all that
stuff but what if what if the best
doesn't exactly mean the most efficient
um you know Allah he created us and our
bodies as a test our bodies are
something we have to take care of and
that's a test for us as well you know so
if you have a child you give birth to
that child someone you have to take care
of Allah the commands that you get if
it's a boy get them circumcised you have
to do it that's a test as well also if
you read like IBN kathir on this uh he
mentions like out of basically all the
animals that there are human beings were
created the best out of what exists not
perfect without a Shadow of Doubt like
pristine but best because we're standing
upright our limbs were basically
beautified and so on and so forth we
have intellect we can talk and so on and
so forth
things like that so I hope that helps
inshallah
um
Pro love what you guys are all doing I
have been looking for a Hello podcast
forever since being given hidayah
mashallah
alhamdulillah
bless you for watching us
and then right from which Palestinian
city urami is originally from I wish it
is not a personal question it's okay
it's I don't mind I'm from tulkaram
that's where my family's from
he's not gonna know where that is by the
way
favorite Halal restaurant in Toronto
bro
um non-kebab is a really good restaurant
bro and this is not a sponsor by the way
they're not paying enough non Kebab
downtown they're pretty on point
um got some good Afghan food there
yeah I want a second that's great um
Gladiator I don't know if it's they have
in Toronto but Mississauga they have
Gladiator it's really good
um there's a monasaba bro manasa bus
it's amazing bro we went there with uh
Gabriel no yeah yeah it's amazing
martial law
um let's see was that the Desi food
that's the Mandy bro oh oof
yeah
writes pretty taboo topic have you guys
heard of the Hadith about the black
banners coming from Horizon
I have heard it um
taboo I don't think it's taboo I've
never heard of that
um I think there is a difference of
opinion I think a lot of the Hadith are
questionable when they start like
surrounding the Mahdi there's a few
things that like we don't know for sure
um but I'm not a scholar gossip scholar
I'm not very educated on this that's
just what I remember hearing from my
teacher
um I have I have heard about it is like
the Afghanistan kind of area
um I know why it's taboo now bro I know
ice Habu because like the the
um I can't say the name the organization
but uh people in power there right now
some people are saying oh they're gonna
be the people with the black flags that
come in don't just bro just listen get
your Islam straight and whatever happens
happens if you witness it you witness it
if not whatever Allah is testing us all
in our own way and whether we know it or
don't know it it's not really gonna
affect us it's not really gonna help us
you know
um
brother Imran writes will y'all ever do
video calling shows sometimes not only
will we we have we've done a few months
ago I think we started this this uh bro
we were on this like wave of like live
call intros and we did that for like a
few weeks I think like three or four
weeks and then we kind of stopped doing
it for a while
um inshallah if we can figure out a more
appropriate way of doing it we will last
time we were a little uneducated
technologically right brother Romy is
killing it right now with streamlabs and
OBS but back then we didn't know what we
were doing doing so I actually posted
this stream yard invite link and then we
only got like 12 people in the waiting
room Max we had like 30 people coming in
it was a whole mess you don't know who's
gonna come in Flash what on the screen
you really don't know you know so we
gotta find the legit way to do it
inshallah
okay next uh swap Neil writes what is
the proper way to approach a woman you
are interested in for marriage how would
you guys approach and Converse about it
well what you're supposed to do is
approach your father and go tell her
father that you're interested in getting
to know his daughter for marriage
um a lot of the time it's a bit like
strange to do that unfortunately
nowadays so a lot of from what I've
heard from Scholars they say just either
give her a note or just indicate to her
go just tell her straight up that I'm
interested in getting to know you for
marriage
um you know and try and get her dad
involved if it's still that like you
know it's like too strange for them to
do it that soon because a lot of fathers
would be like you know don't bring a guy
to me if it's not serious and they give
issues
um then to have a few conversations and
see if it's if it would go somewhere if
there's no like clear-cut like okay I
want kids she doesn't want kids or
something like that and then go to the
father just try and get him involved
ASAP
no I agree 100 and guys smash that like
button 236 viewers right now we should
have a thousand likes you already know
that math makes sense so what are you
guys doing smash that like button if you
want to help it with the algorithm so
sister Ben to Jamil writes how do you
make your Wali and brothers understand
their roles as well we're in a society
where they expect girls to do the
homework I've tried not to talk to men
so I tend them to so I send them to my
brothers but all in vain
subhanallah um you know honestly
in this case if they're not willing to
understand if you go and educate them
and they don't listen and you go to a
Sheikh or a man to go and educate them
and they still won't understand you
might just have to make like in an Imam
I don't want to say it make him your
body yeah because I can't decide that
but you might have to go to an Imam tell
them your situation and say listen I
want you to be the person I can send any
guys who come to me with proposals I
want to send them to you you can vet
them for me you're an Imam it's your
responsibility uh inshallah hopefully
he'll be able to help you if not may
Allah bless you make it easy for you go
see a scholar who knows the fifth of
this what you should do because I can't
give you that answer but that's just
basically off the top of my head
guys listen bro take that [ __ ] on the
screen
no listen I I thought twice about this
and and and I'm not putting this on to
be funny wallahi Allah is my witness
knows that my intention here is
genuinely that this person is seeking an
answer
um could there have been perhaps other
ways of them uh composing this message
in a more uh islamically uh cohesively
etiquette way yes but call us this is
the the fact of reality this is what
they wrote this is what we got to deal
with
um again we're not Scholars but just as
a Layman this is something impure it's
nudges it's and look at all no space bro
like like bro why would you want to do
this that that's another thing it's
because they watch all this does this
Fashion online bro yeah that's
disgusting stuff for Allah
bro just think about it like you're
eating you're eating somewhere you're
licking somewhere
oh bro come on man it's like it's like a
sound fitra should not be
intertwined with wanting to do that you
know what I mean it's just like a
corrupted fitra watching too many adult
you know films it's not even fit though
bro it's like anywhere in their right
mind who would want to eat
who who I want to see you but I'm not
going to say because the algorithm I
know bro you know I'm catching myself
here real smoothly but bro who in the
right mind would want to eat this
Miller protect us bro
um I would again this is not like a fake
ruling but I would categorize this at
the same as I I would say having
intimacy with your wife during that time
of the month it's just impure just dirty
you know except this might be worse bro
I don't know because
I don't know man because at the end of
the day
intimacy with your wife is permissible
and sometimes and then it's
impermissible in that time of the month
but there's still times where it's
permissible whereas this I don't think
there's any time where it's permissible
bro this is like Red Flag Zone bro
I I once had this um
you want to save it for off camera may
Allah forgive me if I say anything out
of place here but and I won't say
anything that's like gonna truly the
algorithm or anything but I had this uh
one guy tell me and this is when I was a
Muslim by the way
he he asked me if I did this act I don't
know of course not bro it's disgusting
it's filth why would anyone in the right
mind do this
and he's like oh bro like after I did
this with my my woman after they were at
the club dancing sweating
bro I remember after he said that I just
looked and I was like
but there's a there's a special place in
hell for people like you bro
that's it's disgusting it's disgusting
uh brother Sharif writes how to build a
six-figure income
y'all Rich Montreal
win in Montreal and we are from Richmond
yeah but uh again we will quickly we
made an episode a few weeks ago about
how to how to get rich quick something
there's some clickbaity title you know
how we are shamelessly clickbaity but uh
aside from that I would say right now
um watch some of brother Iman gaji's
videos it is not a good opportunity
right now in the economy to do a lot of
things right we'll add a little bit of a
dip right now because of inflation this
is not Financial advice before anyone
gives us a strike
um but I recommend you guys to start
worrying about cash flow find ways to
secure cash flow right now and within
the next one to two years
um the recession will be at the worst
that's when you want to kind of go in
and get assets that's going to be your
game plan crypto land real estate
everything like that for now just secure
on getting cash flow this could be in
starting up businesses this could be
starting up
um passive income streams uh again a lot
of controversy right now you know
passive income in the in the modern
sense doesn't really exist because you
still need to do some work
um but yeah just worry about something
like that and uh if you want to do a 905
cool but definitely start some side
hustles too a lot of opportunities to
make money inshallah online
next uh we got one from uh Anthony
writes one can I have a hug inshallah as
soon as I see you man as soon as we see
you bro you can't see me right now as
soon as I see everybody Anthony bro let
us know in the comments right now how
your journey to Islam is going mashallah
may Allah bless brother Anthony he
accepted Islam a few I would say months
ago and then he got on our show too
um just to kind of convey his message I
think it was one of the call-in shows uh
but again may Allah bless you and I
believe uh one of the biggest influences
for you aside from obviously Allah
having you know giving hidayah was
him I saw Anthony on the one message
Foundation Channel that's when he got on
the channel they talked about
Christianity they talked about Islam and
then I believe he became Muslim soon
after inshallah international law
well you know what I got in my mind
though
you remember the the one song back in
the day I think it was like gotta eat
the Booty like groceries or something
like that
um
yeah
bro
I was just gonna say it I swear bro a
lot of these songs from like back in
jail obviously because we don't listen
to music though but back in jaheliyah
all these songs like they would actually
normalize things that are not natural
bro and they would actually talk about
these things in a way where it's like
wow like all these rappers are really
like aspiring for this you know this is
like amazing you know like a lot of
these songs for example there were some
two chain songs Gucci Mane Migos a lot
of them would say basically I'm not
gonna give the lyrics no but they would
talk about a girl who would be very
physically attractive and they're like
yo you're so physically attractive the
whole world should see that and I want
to show you off bro what the hell is
that
in the youth nasty that's Fox a writes
and by the way guys we have two minutes
left so any any last minute questions
please send it our way inshallah we will
be doing more live streams uh mainly in
our second Channel all right links in
the description for a second channel
it's called the three Muslims clips for
now but we're gonna rename it revamp it
and everything uh we did get a Super
Chat just now so please send your last
minute Super Shots right now we will
address all of them and insha Allah
until next time uh brother a writes is
it haram to kiss your wife and guys
please get the likes up smash that like
button what I mean what do you think no
it's not hot up to kiss your wife you
should kiss your wife um tell her you
love her as well make her feel womanly
and happy inshaallah please your wife
the prophet sallam said be good to your
woman so be good to her inshallah
there's one more Super Chat bro from
fajada I do want to talk about it let's
do it bro
all right she's gonna one one sec
there's a one from a YouTube member I
don't want to forget this
is bear with those guys one second night
of decree oh it's just a martial law
alhamdulillah all right so brother Fahad
Malik writes Brothers I have chosen to
leave Islam a couple months back I am
looking for true purpose in life and I
wanted to know what are things people
can do to find meaning outside of
practicing Islam I've left most of
social media
all right so I I wanna I wanna give you
the the the tough truth if you're not if
you don't believe in God all right let's
just say that generally if you're not a
Muslim right if you don't believe in God
you can never have objective purpose you
can never because atheism leads to moral
nihilism which is there's no morality
there's no there's there's no good or
bad there's no objective truth there's
nothing basically and when I die I'll be
nothing as well and there's nothing
afterwards you cannot have a purposeful
an objectively purposeful life after
that so I'm sorry you're heading down to
nothingness you're going to end up very
depressed if you go down this path
hit me up inshaallah hit up the three
Muslims hit me up in my my private
Instagram even let's just talk about
Islam let's talk about purpose let's
talk about why we've been put on this
Earth I think it's amazing that you love
social media so maybe you should send me
us an email instead but you're not gonna
find purpose outside of God and religion
it might be making money that's gonna
make you depressed it might be getting
women that's going to make you depressed
and there's nothing on the face of the
Earth that will make you happy and
content because that's how Allah created
us message us insha Allah let's get on a
call let's have a conversation
alhamdulan guys we we make time for
these things this is not something like
new or anything like that
um basically a few uh a few days ago me
and brother Romy I don't say this to
boast but we literally had a call with a
brother not gonna mention any names and
he left Islam you know and we tried to
answer his questions he asked us
questions we answered it and so this is
something we we do we offer this this is
not something we're gonna shy away from
and I do want to say that you know a lot
of the times when brothers and sisters
unfortunately leave Islam it's do you it
really boils down to two things number
one it's either extreme miseducation or
misinformation so they look at videos
like scientific errors in the Quran or
uh logical contradictions about Islam
and these are clowns on youtube the
YouTubers that make these videos by the
way they use different translations of
the Quran they use things that are out
of context and they they need to make
money obviously so they need this Market
to exist so they're going to keep making
these videos to keep misinforming the
youth and people that don't know any
better they're going to look at a video
being like oh wow there's scientific
errors in the Quran without knowing the
proper transition in context and and the
meaning of words linguistically they're
going to be like wow I didn't even know
this and it's kind of like a paradigm
shift you know so that's number one and
number two they want to live life in a
guilt-free manner and this god-level
accountability they don't want that bro
because it's it's too much easier or
blue pill to be like you know what there
is no God therefore I can do XYZ stop
for Allah but that's why we don't really
think it's an informed decision and it's
not rational so please reach out to us
our Instagram is the three Muslims just
like you see our name right here at an
at in front of it that's for Instagram
our email is going to be the same name
you see the three Muslims gmail.com
Tick Tock tool but please reach out on
Instagram that's the best way to find us
um and yeah anything you guys want to
say we've got one more Super Chat
for the possibly will stay in touch
thank you brother just to be clear as I
believe in a lot alhamdulillah inshallah
that's great brother may Allah bless you
and bring you back to Islam hit us up
inshallah it's gone on that conversation
and unfortunately we do have to end it
now so don't send any more Super chats
we can't read anymore uh but just like
for everyone who sent the super chats
who asks a question who you know
contributed to the live stream I love
bust you all immensely uh it's just as
important that you guys are here that it
is that we're here alhamdulillah from
Allah we come to him we will turn do you
guys want to add anything before we end
off yeah so I just wanted to give a
quick thing bro I know we got to do
another uh recording right now guys stay
tuned for Thursday you got a raw episode
coming this Thursday Insha'Allah
um hashtag Andrew Tate if you want a
little teaser what it's going to be
about but I know Rami no I'm not
confused right now and I will explain
after the stream but quickly I want to
give a little bit of a nasiha inshallah
um to our brothers and sisters that are
tuning in if you see someone struggling
with Islam just like this brother I saw
a little you know a little uh sauce
comment or two here listen we don't come
here with hate we don't come at these
brothers and sisters vilifying them the
reality is a lot of them have left
because of the way Muslims have treated
them bro it's not about Islam but it's
their experience with Muslims a lot of
the time not every time and because of
this it's absolutely imperative that we
have the most other in terms of
etiquette manners respect not in terms
of accepting their worldview but empathy
and sympathy and emotional intelligence
and understanding that okay maybe
they're struggling with something right
now it's not too far-fetched to
understand why they would be struggling
with this in modernism you know all
these isms going on today all this
programming and brainwashing and because
of this it's absolutely crucial that we
keep this mind and we understand okay
it's actually a blessing that Allah has
guided Us in the first place let's not
take this for granted let's not act like
wow I'm amazing therefore I'm Muslim no
it's the mercy of Allah that has decided
to guide you and because of this let's
have a little bit of Mercy for our
brothers and sisters a little bit of
empathy and and truly lead by example so
that you bring them closer to Allah and
not farther
I mean all right
bless you all and with that being said